chuck you want to live on mars yes but
you can't breathe air no
all right so we have two options okay
we're all gonna move to mars and live
there either we build a biodome habitat
okay that's basically earth on mars i
kind of like that idea okay but then you
can't just wander it's not your planet
you're you the biodome is kind of like a
global spacesuit for everybody
so it's not so it's hard for me it would
be hard to call that home it'd be like
the truman show on mars you can only go
to a certain limit and then that's right
so another option would be to terraform
the place okay and one of my favorite
words get your ass tomorrow
telephone get your ass to mars what
stop hogging up the rpg
so so here's the thing the
terraforming mars terraforming mars so
so here's why everyone's talking about
mars and not venus you ever wonder why
uh okay here's why because men are from
mars
venus is 900 degrees fahrenheit okay
runaway greenhouse effect wow and i did
the calculation okay you could put a
pizza on the windowsill it'll cook in
nine seconds not bad
here's the thing mars
rotates once about every 24 hours okay
did you know that that's kind of what we
do and it's tipped on its axis kind of
like what we as we are it has polar ice
caps so do we as we do and on its
surface there's all this evidence that
it once had running water uh
meandering riverbeds bone dry today
right okay we're headed there too
it's just so so mars just got
everybody's imagination so
there's no water there now but there was
once where do you think the water went
um
underground well we don't really know
okay no but we think underground oh
thank god
i was just guessing like wildly no
if it went anywhere it went underground
right and mars is very cold and so we
think it's like a permafrost permanently
permanently frozen down there all right
so what you want to do is you want to
warm the planet
get the water back on the surface okay
and there's not much atmosphere there
it's mostly carbon dioxide right which
is what kind of a gas
greenhouse a greenhouse gas but it's
only one percent
the thickness of our atmosphere so even
though it's almost entirely co2 it's not
thick enough to trap the heat coming
from the martian surface there you go
that got there from the sun right so
that's how that works sunlight comes in
which is mostly visible light correct
it's absorbed by the soils right
and it re-radiates in infrared that's
what gets trapped right by greenhouse
gases but with no atmosphere with the
thin atmosphere but there's nothing
going on right so it's cold so
everybody's wondering let's warm the
place all right can we release some of
the co2 that's frozen on the poles can
we get the water back out you know the
water molecule is also a greenhouse gas
that's right did you know water vapor is
probably the most prevalent greenhouse
gases
in our atmosphere correct there's more
water vapor than anything else right if
you get all the co2 that we have found
in the polar ice caps all right because
it's like dry ice there okay because dry
ice on earth is co2 right okay so
so you'd get all that evaporate it then
get all the water evaporate that it's
still not enough to make a big
difference in the greenhouse trapping
of mars oh wow
so if we want to warm the planet you
gotta byo
b-y-o-g-h-g
yes
bring your own greenhouse gas great
b-y-o-g-h-g i think we can do that you
think we can do that all right i mean
methane we can bring methane methane
another greenhouse gas we can bring some
methane how are you gonna do that well
there's just you know eat a lot of chili
meat and beans
methane
i believe that's the molecular
combination from that
chemistry book and beans
methane
so bring everybody just with some chili
bowls
everybody gets a volatility welcome
tomorrow here's it bullets help out
how about the locals
how about the ecology here's your bowl
of chili
but farm animals also give off methane
you get that from because the it when
they digest cellulose which is the
fibers and plant life so
uh cow multiple stomach animals are
they're burping and and and
all kinds of stuff all orphans are
giving off the the methane right
termites do it too i didn't know that
yeah a big source of methane in the
world so i tell my wife all the time i'm
just like we have termites
that wasn't me
that wasn't me you can't blame the dog
no we don't have dogs i've got to blame
the termites
but so the problem is there's not enough
in
on planet carbon dioxide and water vapor
to pull this off so you have to bring
your own or find some other way to heat
the planet
and elon musk has a plan uh-oh
okay so he's he's thinking of putting
satellites in orbit that have big
reflectors that focus sunlight that
would otherwise miss the planet right
focus it down on the planet and just add
more energy to the planet heating it up
and if you do it right you might be able
to set sort of a
chain reaction in place if everything is
frozen and it gets warmer you'll
evaporate more carbon dioxide and
that'll help trap more heat and then
that'll make it harder to evaporate even
more carbon dioxide you get all of that
out of the system and into the
atmosphere then now it's warm enough now
you're still mostly greenhouse gases you
still need oxygen to breathe right so
now you put
microorganisms that eat this the co2 and
they they release they release oxygen
like plants do that but
on earth there's something called
cyanobacteria right they change the
ecology of the earth more than anything
else that has ever happened including
humans wow we had a mostly carbon
dioxide atmosphere the cyanobacteria
said i'm eating some of that it sounds
good it sounds good and out comes oxygen
they created an oxygen uh after a rich
atmosphere right wow
and then everything else is kind of
based off of that based off of that
everything else we know and love right
here's the question what how long does
this
so i i don't that's the big problem is
it a thousand years is it a million
years or it's can you speed it up with
some you know
fast-acting
microbes this remains to be established
but i'm telling you that if we're going
to be a two planet species i'm thinking
you got to terraform mars for that to
happen nice and is mars the best planet
of all the planets to terrify i'm not
burning my ass on venus a okay b
i'm not going to mercury because it's
three inches from the surface of the sun
okay okay they could be moons of outer
planets like moons of jupiter moons are
jupiter and saturn okay titan has an
atmosphere uh-huh okay you might be able
to terraform that if we have the right
formulas and recipes but we're not
really there yet not even there there's
way in the future so mars is the closest
thing to us with the best possible
results correct and so and it's new and
it's nearby and it's and it's got
as close as we could have ever wanted i
think to pull off this experiment
so so yeah yeah
and has it occurred to anyone that
perhaps we should just take care of this
planet
here no here's the thing
the day we have the power
to
terraform mars
to turn mars into earth
we will have the power to turn earth
into earth
oh that is awesome
i never thought of that if we could
terraform mud people are saying oh we
need are we going to tell from mars move
there because we've trashed earth right
and i'm saying it means that we're able
to geo-engineer our own planet to a
place where
we could turn earth back into earth it's
not a bad answer it's a good answer but
here's another problem
escape plan we need a place to go
because we'll get hit by a giant
asteroid so you want to just you want to
become a two planet species right in
case there's a risk of
a catastrophic collision with some
celestial body okay so what you're
saying is we ship a billion people there
we got billions here and then one of
them goes extinct and while the others
watch
you know i kind of like that
i'm just saying that's kind of cool
like like if i'm on mars and earth gets
hit with that you're cool with that i am
so cool
so here's the thing
go ahead
i don't know if it's just me right
whatever it takes
to
terraform mars right from advanced
geoengineering yes
it seems to me that by then we could
just
bat asteroids out of the sky
as they come it seems to me will be
advanced enough to have a perfect
anti-virus serum
so that there's no killer virus that
takes it out it seems to me we have the
power to protect either planet from
anything that could render us extinct
something's telling me you have a bias
towards earth i like me
earth is good
so chuck we done here oh we're done
so let's say you just wanted to get some
video footage of mars you would have to
build a spaceship commission nasa to do
your mission control work go to mars
have a special camera take actual
footage of mars who do you think you are
nasa or you could do what we did
story blocks that's right that's how we
got access to shots like this
and this
and this we got them all from
storyblocks storyblocks video has video
and images and audio and templates for
anything you want mars stuff
boom scary stuff boom clowns
scary clowns yes unfortunately even that
yeah some of the video in this video
came from storyblocks so head to
storyblocks.com
and sign up now check out their
unlimited plan for all the royalty-free
media you could ever wish for check out
the link in the description below and
learn more about storyblocks video
and as always
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]